foreign
here's what I expect
the thing I want to emphasize is that
there's plural there's AIS so this idea
of the monolithic AI taking over they're
just they're like machines and they're
they follow the general engineering
Maxim which is that you cannot optimize
everything there's always trade-offs so
we're going to engineer these AIS to be
good for certain things but not as good
as something else in another dimension
and we already see that with say the
image generator some favorite artists
some favorite photography there'll be
different personalities the one that
does painting the best probably isn't
going to be the best for writing
there'll be some kind of transformative
or anything bad at hands and so I say
the general stance we're going to have
is what I call dumb schmarten okay
there'd be really smart and is that
Pennsylvania Dutch well I don't know
it's kind of like that it's Amish Martin
we're just going to be furious it's like
how could you be so dumb when you're so
smart about these other things this is
going to be their typical reaction it's
like you're insanely brilliant but
you're so dumb here sounds like half of
Silicon Valley exactly and I'm smart
it'll be more and more difficult to kind
of generalize but what I'm saying is
that they're going to be engineered for
specific tasks primarily and there will
be a general one but the general one
would be kind of like like the Swiss
army knife yeah you know it's like good
generally but not really the best in any
one tool yeah that's the engineering
Maxim so we should expect multiple
varieties of these
and for me the best stance is to think
of them as artificial aliens okay aliens
meaning they could be like Spock or
yoded very very smart but they
they're just doing things differently
than we were doing if they have a sense
of humor it'll be a little off
but that is actually their benefit
because they help us think different and
that's what we're going to be using them
for that's what people are already using
for is generate ideas like there's
probably an idea that no human would
ever come up with and that helps me come
up with a new idea
the third thing I would say about the
AIS is that most of them will be unseen
they'll be behind the Office operating
things the plumbing the infrastructure
and that's actually a sign of their
success
technology succeed when we don't see
them anymore we don't think about them
they become boring
and that the majority of the stuff won't
even be outward facing it'll be just
behind the scenes and
and then this idea of consciousness
Consciousness is a liability
you don't want your car to be conscious
you want to drive you don't want to be
wary about whether it should major in
finance you want it to focus on the road
so there will be advertising AIS as
cautious free dumb and obedience yes
exactly extra thirty dollars per month
exactly so
I would say a couple things one is I
think AI overall is under hyped but the
current version we won't even call AI in
30 years we'll look back and that's that
wasn't it and so it means that there's
no AI experts right now
but in the short time we're probably
overestimating this idea like
vast unemployment stuff not in the next
couple of years for sure so everything
you've said makes sense tools will get
specialized
they will become so embedded that we
will cease to think about them hopefully
and hopefully right in the same way that
you waved at the lights you know we have
all sorts of Lights in here but
it's not like we walk into any room with
artificial light and we think
good Lord what is this miracle of
engineering and human ingenuity
I think most folks be like okay okay so
why is it under hyped right well what
should surprise people or what what are
people not appreciating
so I was involved with the internet I
was living online for at least 10 years
before 1992-93 when wire started
and in a certain sense it's like
we couldn't get anybody to take it
seriously it was dismissed as teenage
boys stuff and it was kind of that's
what it was but
I felt like no this is like this is
really significant this is really
powerful and what changed it was an
interface change it became visual for
the first time in the web was pictures
and stuff and that's when everybody
Switched at it most of the AI happening
today has been happening with all these
chap has been happening for years what's
new is that we now have an interface we
have the conversational it's this idea
of the large language model we have a
conversational interface and that
suddenly was like
the power that's been there for years
has now suddenly accessible it's like
having the pictures on the web
and so we're suddenly thinking about it
suddenly in people's faces in the same
way that the internet was completely
Fringe and then when the web came along
it very rapidly
became mainstream I remember the first
time I saw my gas station the pump there
was like a URL I was like oh my gosh
this is like it's here this is I have
the same feeling right now happening
with the chatbots and the and the image
generators is these capabilities have
been around for at least a decade but
now what's new is we have a
a language interface a conversational
interface with them and the powers is
sort of completely in our faces now and
so where do we go from there I think we
are going to then start to apply this to
everything right it's going to be I mean
as we speak every day there's people
embedding this and they're going to
embed it with this interface so I think
we're going to move to this
having a whole nother level of
interfacing with this machine with
language and
that's very very powerful we'll just go
through the whole thing it's like
take X
and the
language interface to it that's really
powerful